bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you I'm ready your host
you're watching the Dean show and today
we're going to be bringing out chick
came out of Mickey and he's going to
help us sing this song so you want to be
a gangster smoking all that dope
disrespecting people and all the folk
that's what you think is about man you
think that is what makes you successful
being a punk a thug well the share when
I tell my milkshake he's got something
else to tell you so if your parents
brought you down to watch the Dean
she'll sit tight because we'll have some
fun but we're going to be serious don't
go nowhere we'll be right back this
this is the this is the thing you
alaikum Salaam I don't know where you
got that song from boo you know what it
covers our topic nicely I think you know
what way back I used to be in Jogja Leah
and I learned so much and I thank the
creator of the heavens herb that he
guided me and I used to listen to the
hip hop right and you know what you're
singing in there thinking about all
sorts of stuff disrespect to the parents
disrespect to yourself disrespect to
your teachers disrespecting the woman
and now the youth as I was I thought it
was cool to disrespect people because
they're people and this is what happens
in the high school and the colleges and
whatnot the more disrespectful you are
the more you're you know the cool guy
people be dissing each other be dissing
each other right you know most people
say that you're black you know that
right most people what's the Dean show
they say Eddie's black well you know
what they see that you know what what we
talking about here sponsor my cuts your
thumb nah but here's the thing here's
the thing no I we try to keep it real we
try to to connect with the youth because
we are in a real world and I was living
that life and I see that's the wrong
direction to go so now i feel is
requires discipline to hold back and
you're angry can I throw a punch you
have to stay comedy patients with islam
teaches it's easier to let out profanity
it's easy to be a thug so that's what we
want to talk to why do you think more
people inclined to that it's easy but
this it takes some discipline and they
kind of go towards the easier ride let's
discuss this very important fantastic
let me begin by saying this min left
with hamdullah or salatu salam o Laila
but those who don't know that means in
the name of Allah and all praise is due
to Allah and may he extolled and send
blessings of peace
fun his final messenger mohammed and
obviously upon all the profits that he
sent before now take a note just just
just I'm sorry to cut your you sit Allah
and again there's a lot of not yet
Muslims they tune in they hear a la they
think in God they think a black box and
desert we gotta say about that it's just
how you say God in Arabic you know you
go to if you go to almost an Arab
country all right arab country and you
go into a church the Bible says allah in
arabic if you go to a synagogue for
example morocco yemen there many Jews or
Arabs or speak Arabic and their Bible
says Allah as well so it's proof it's
the same God not a different gun so
that's all we're saying ok good I'm
sorry please continue now what I loved
about how you began is that you actually
said a hadith because the prophets of
allah allah says I'm said in a session
ii no sora he said that the the strong
person isn't the one who out wrestles
people because or lose your temper or
you use profanity that's easy anybody
could do that the strong person is one
who contains his anger you know who
keeps his cool keeps his temper down
that's the strong person because you
agree that that's harder to contain
yourself than it is to erupt anybody can
interrupt use bad words you know you
sign language anyways i do that
absolutely i speak french yeah some
people do not pay they communicate in
these ways and they think they're and
then they come in boast about these
things they boast about how they went
off on this guy and then i said this
time but that's easy how do you bullish
about something that's easy you boast
about something that's difficult so if
someone really got up in your face as
they say and you know was rude and
disrespectful and you could contain
yourself that's something now you can
boast about nothing you just curse them
back anybody can do that but what is
going on now with people even even you
find sometimes practicing Muslims if i
can use that term and they still have
that thug thing going on you know that
mentality they don't want to smile and
shake your hand they just give you the
cold salaams what's going on should I
monocle Oh hard and stuff what's with
this hard thing you know it's it's
pushed too much I mean obviously and
you've interviewed rappers before and
they all said that it's an image right
this year they not hard all the time and
they don't
a couple hard yeah it's an image thing
but then these young people they see it
on television and then they believe it
that's how you have to be one group did
this kind of a study if you want to call
it and then you start to interview kids
at high schools and they would ask them
what is a map and everything that youth
would say back into the camera was
violent or aggressive and they felt at
them and they would use words like a man
is powerful it was aggressive you know
he's a good fighter he takes you know
matters to his own hands he does
everything they were mentioning was
aggressive because that is the immediate
definition that you get from the
mainstream media of what a man is you're
the man is violent and the man takes
care of issues not not my diplomacy and
speaking that's for weaklings the nerds
will finish the head will solve their
disputes that way you know the man he he
jumps out of his car takes off his coat
there was a glasses off man fisticuffs
punches people out knock people up
where'd they get this from so this
violence thing is going overboard but
it's all from you know the movies that
glorifies they know the fighting the the
aggressive behavior and from just like
you know the stuff that you're quoting
earlier that the rap music and talking
about violence and how tough they are
how many times you have to listen to a
song about how tough a guy is and in
reality he's not tough he's got a pool
boy he's got a mansion and you know he's
living the easy life but he talks about
how toffee is in the studio all the time
and then people fall for that yeah what
an interesting thing tell us I really
love this in the Quran when local man
was was a righteous wise man in the past
and he was advising his son so one of
the he was getting a lot of advice with
manners with life with staying away from
worshiping things besides Allah with
being good to the parents and then one
of the things he tells him he's starting
to gives him starts to give him advice
on being humble and having humility so
he told him what to say error hidaka
Nina's and do not just saw your your
cheek to people do not turn your cheek
to people Sal is a disease that afflicts
camels and when it afflicts them their
neck turns and their first turns to the
side isn't weird any that arrogant
people and the thugs they don't
straight they always walk to the side
like this you see a girl walking like
this just like the Quran described he'll
turn his face so he was advising decides
that don't turn your face to the people
meaning don't become arrogant be humble
in how you carry yourself be humble and
how you deal with people tlg have you
heard of that no it is not tlg and I
feel that people just today I just
follows tan laundry and Jim have you
heard that no never I guess I'm not a
hip like that so you watch these reality
shows and these people who are out there
glorifying this lifestyle just more
about the body more about you know
physical appearances and they forget
they forget about purifying the soul
they forget about the reality of death
they forget about returning to their
creator so these things it seems like
you know we focus more on the physical
our appearances and then at the same
time you know we don't watch our
behavior and again it just seems again
from early on from the high schools
public schools it just seems like the
whole culture is making it easy so how
does someone who has been programmed for
so many years how do they get out of
this and of course it's visual any
improvement that you can make any self
improvement if it wasn't possible Allah
wouldn't ask you to do it so if you
couldn't change yourself to become more
humbled and then have more humility then
I love wouldn't ask you or require that
of you so the truth is and the good news
is that you can improve and you can
change from you know being arrogant to
being in a state of humility you know
the Prophet sallallahu said upset in the
hadith man o Allah din da hee ha ha ha
short hadid deep in meaning whoever
humbles himself for the sake of Allah
Allah will raise him in rank you imagine
it's the opposite you know you act all
arrogant and then you know you get
better status with people but it's
actually the opposite you humble
yourself for the sake of allah and allah
so how to i will raise you in rank and
by the way you know a lot of people
think you know if you're being
humble that means again you're weak
you're letting people to step on you and
has nothing to do with them humility is
just the opposite of arrogance you know
and it's interesting how arrogance
itself the arrogant people alice is not
an inner latina astagfirullah an Emirati
see the whole una johana medically those
who were too arrogant to worship me a
lesson in the Quran those were too
arrogant to worship me they get a
punishment that the opposite they were
enter the Hellfire in the state of
humility also person described that the
people were like really arrogant got
their nose in the air they think they're
all that as they say these people out of
out of the embarrassment and punishment
Allah will raise them on the Day of
Resurrection on the size of little ants
and people will not see them and they'll
be fun not to let people step over them
so we need to humble ourselves
absolutely let's take a break and be
right back Marta disha and it's simple
to understand I wouldn't know what the
sky looked like what the trees look like
I would have never seen the faces of my
beautiful children if I didn't have the
ability to see how blessed we are by
Allah and obedience is born out of
gratitude so thank him call upon him
establish a relationship with him forget
about the past take it out of being a
ritual and make it a spiritual
experience Islam is not something
dubious unclear hazy it's really
straightforward he said it changed his
life he said he saw every single episode
that you had ever recorded back here on
the Dean show with shake him out of
Mecca we're talking about serious
business we're talking about things that
are very important it's not just about
getting to 10 doing the laundry the
clothes getting ready for the nightclub
on the weekend hitting the bench press
that's all you focused on you're not
thinking about anything else because you
got to go get you honey you got to go
fulfill your lusts and desires and the
woman sheet the man's on the hunt and
the woman is just acquiring as many
phone numbers as you can so she can have
her phone blowing up ringing and it
becomes a whole game and we get caught
up into this whole system and if we
forget about our purpose in life why
we've been created and we start doing
things that are displeasing to the one
who created us why is the
again I keep asking a million dollar
question why are people more inclined to
this nowadays right and obviously you
know if I were to take the easy route
i'll just say you know it's it's like a
V man it like a you know belief yeah are
the belief is weak in people's hearts a
lack of knowledge when the dunya becomes
the dunya meaning this material world
becomes great in people's hearts you
know and because the dunya is great
because people envy them each other hate
each other because of things of the
material world like you know even a good
person will see someone with a nice
vehicle and they'll envy that they'll be
jealous of it you're only jealous
because a couple of things one this
material world is great in your heart
otherwise it's just a piece of metal it
wouldn't have mattered to you that the
the material world has become great in
people's hearts the other thing also
you'll find people you know they're to
what code meaning their trust in their
reliance in the last week you know a lot
owns everything in the heavens on the
earth if a guy has a Ferrari Allah gave
it to him he could give it to you to the
water bottle or maybe he's not giving it
to for a good reason so don't worry
about but because material things have
become so great in our hearts that that
we want to express who we are through
our material possessions yeah and so
you'll find even it something you find
some very hollow people who they won't
even have a car but to have a
mercedes-benz kitchen although just
twirl it around like this yeah as I talk
to girls and stuff yeah you got to see
the bend simple huh yeah the three-point
starter idea trying to show that I got a
Benz and the guys taking the city bus
you know yeah so but because the world
has become so great in people's minds
and hearts that they always try to
express who they are through their
belongings and through their possessions
some cities i'm not going to say what
city but in certain cities where most
people don't drive i think i gave it
away people try to express what they're
through what they're wearing so they try
to worry the flashiest outfits other
states for example where you know it's
not really about what you wear it's
about the car that you drive so he will
put everything into that car yeah i
remember one time I dropped off as some
people at a homeless shelter they were
staying there and there was a guy with a
brand-new Lexus living at the homeless
shelter so for the moments when he's out
of the homeless shelter
having Alexis everybody would look up
them like oh he's got money but he
doesn't even have a house the guy's
homeless and he's broken is unemployed
but he put everything into this car so
he could live that fake image you know
and and also it brings to mind the
hadith of the Prophet I'm mentioning and
he says some people in the worst
position or the worst of people one of
them is I stuck a good like someone who
is poor yet he's arrogant what are you
being arrogant about the guys poor he's
got no money but it's still being
arrogant so you'll find the guy who's
homeless he puts everything that he has
into a car then you'll drive it looking
all arrogant like he's so he's living
the life so this is this the easy way
this is easy to be a thug to act out a
line to go and lift some weights here is
nothing wrong with lifting weights
there's nothing wrong with being cleaned
doing your laundry and all this stuff
but now it takes some discipline to
control yourself to stay away from evil
this requires some effort and work but
isn't the outcome better they're just
living according to your lusts and
desires absolutely i mean the problem
even promised us that you know those who
were humbled and they don't have that
attitude and all that and think too hard
themselves the process LMK said month o
allah la hija que de so the probe salem
said whoever humbles himself to a love
like this then he turns his hand
downwards and he lowers it all the way
down near to the ground the narrator
says then he's been he turned to this is
rafa a whole lot or a low will raise him
yet for Allah hi Kayla then he turns his
hand he's a low a grazing like this then
he starts raising his hand up up I are
not until he went as I see could go so
you humble yourself a low will raise you
whether it means as what people think of
you in the community your position your
actual rank your status or you'll rank
with Allah subhana tada as well to a low
and raise you from acting humble not
from being like a thug here now someone
might be watching the show now and
they'll argue well we see all these
people who act arrogant and act like
thugs and people look up to them yes
it's not the opposite of what you're
saying well in the end people look up to
them what
people look up to them yeah most of the
you'll see that they're worthless people
who look up to them because allah
describes this in the quran describing
fir'aun pharaoh he said first offer como
oh what's the common foe yani it means
he belittled his people so they
respected him he they respected him when
he treated them like dirt which means
they have no self-worth they don't have
self-respect because anyone with
self-respect if you treat them like dirt
they say look I want to deal with this
person anymore but the Griffin will
respect you if you if you treat them
like dirt themselves loli loli
individual so if you're telling me these
rappers do act like in the arrogant and
the athletic thuds and they get respect
from people they're getting respect from
people who have no self-respect that's
number one and and the second thing
they're respect is limited to what they
have into their status you know any of
these full any of these rappers or
what-have-you they become less popular
nobody remembers them anymore you know
if you want rapper steps out of the
limelight the next day the next guy is
is popular and nobody remembers him
anymore yeah I don't think we need to
mention any names right so so tell us
why do you think many of the youth they
join gangs a number of things sense of
belonging you know also to feel
important you know human beings the
psychologists say there are social
beings so they want to belong right and
people also need to want to feel
important everybody loves loves
themselves you know if anyone tells you
they don't love themselves hit him on
the face and see what they can defend
them so because they love themselves
yeah of course don't do that but the
idea is people love themselves right and
they tell you like you know everybody
loves their name even the letter of your
name if you see it you know understudies
they'll see that your brain will light
up more when they say the letter of your
name you know so if you see an e your
brain will light up more than a B if I
cak my brain will light up more so
everybody loves themselves when you look
at the class photo the first thing you
look you look for yourself you're like
where's Jimmy you look for yourself
right so people love themselves they
want to feel important and they want to
feel needed as well and they want to
part of a group and so a lot of youth
then instead of going to the right group
instead of going to their mosque their
message into the community you know to
the shelf to the righteous people either
might get lost to them but and then look
for a sense of belonging with that kind
of group and it's amazing the kinds of
things people will do to become accepted
by a certain group of individuals like
they'll go to the point you know you've
heard about hazing of course hazing
actually has a lot of psychology in it
when when someone does something
ridiculous related to hazing like to
make someone no dressing is underwear in
the winter and run across you know in
front of people they actually because
they're doing something so ridiculous
they convince themselves that I really
want to be part of this group that's why
I'm willing to go as far as doing
something so ridiculous and humiliate
myself because I want any part of this
group human beings have that need to
belong and gangs offer that
unfortunately they offer that yeah so
we're going to continue more asking some
more questions here at additional know
where it's like when did you think that
you had no purpose are you worthless the
value comes from purpose your purpose in
life is to worship the Creator no
worship your desires himself not worship
social pressure the celebrity culture
but worship the thing that's much higher
and transcendent above and beyond by
worshiping golden seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure we're here on the day so thank
you for joining us and we're talking
about it's easy to be a thug it's easy
to follow your lusts and desires but it
takes a little more effort doing the
good things that the crater told us to
do and I think that's the cool thing
people feel that that's not cool but how
can we again bring it home where that is
not the cool thing being disrespectful
to your parents being disrespectful to
your teachers being disrespectful to
your classmates being respectful to your
peers that's not cool what's cool is
being
platform being dignified showing
humility bringing home shift option you
know I love blaming the media what's
wrong with that oblem and I studied I
studied me to production I studied
communication so we studied the theory
behind television the theory behind
radio all kinds of things related to
that and one of the things is that you
know this is you know the media they
claim that it doesn't affect people's
behavior but it will affect what's in
the forefront of your mind right so if a
young person sees that the proper way is
the respectful guy is you're saying the
humble guy is always presented as a
square the nerd you know you always see
the proper guy who uses proper language
and has a shirt tucked in wears his
glasses is always like socially inept is
always the nerd and the clown even in
sitcoms even in children sitcoms you
know these disney channel to have these
all these sitcoms for kids they always
show the cool guy is kind of
disrespectful and kind of you know
carefree and what have you and then the
proper guy is always uncool so then they
get this image yeah you know being
proper and right and we're in good in
language and respect that manners you're
uncool you know you're socially inept
you're a nerd and it was dressing up
weird with bow ties and stuff like that
yeah but then the guy who is got bad man
it's got a little bit of attitude he
cracks the funny jokes and everything in
front in class he's the cool gun so then
it remains and then they want to act out
these certain scenes in the classroom
fun a lot of kids now disrespecting the
teacher trying to be funny trying to
disrespect this disrupt the class
because they learned that's what it is
to be cool but of course cool is uncool
on the day of judgment right whatever
school here you mean if what it was
wrong and that people make is cool it's
uncool in the day of judgment that's my
next that leads me to my next question
the day of judgment and before that to
help people realize this series of this
matter that def is approaching and can
you just explain emphasize what will
happen in the grave when you die and
that
Jamela commode angel death comes to take
you so well you know it everyone thinks
they have time to repent or it's not
going to happen to me and they told you
also this is one of the things that
happens in the minds of youth they
always think the accident will happen to
the other gun but not to me so we always
think that death will come to me in my
deathbed when I have my family around me
but I'm like I'm not the guy was going
to be killed in the street suddenly
going to work going to school but the
truth is it will happen and it does
happen to people young and old and so
when you die you have to be prepared for
it when the Angel of Death Comes to you
can't repent anymore and when you're put
in your grave you're going to be asked
three questions now even if you studied
these questions in school you can't
answer it unless you're a believer who
is your Lord and only believe it can
answer that someone who read a book of
what Islam didn't become Muslim can't
answer this question either who's a
believer one who who worships the One
God alone without any partners not his
creation and the last in His Messenger
and his messenger muhammad saw that
would include all the preceding
messengers Jesus Moses Abraham Oliver
absolutely and all the books and all the
angels you have that belief you're a
Muslim and then doing all the good that
God Almighty's calls to do it staying
away from the evil because it's not
enough it's not good enough to just know
that there is a God is you need to do it
toxins are you more than words
absolutely so you can't answer these
questions in the grave who's your Lord
who's your profit what is your religion
so that's why everyone you you have to
become Muslim you have to repent you
have to abide by the rules and forget
what's in the media ok and a Muslim is
simply one who submits it is great
that's what it means not so man to a
monkey or feels creator that's it and
you get rewards for just tell us briefly
now you give rewards that if you want to
be a thug you want to act out of control
but you contain yourself do you get
rewards for leaving off the evil and
doing good to motivate them to do more
good than rather than evil upon the
crater absolutely anybody who lives
thuggery gets the reward for living that
in sha allah and you get the good deeds
absolutely you get the good deep and
some the some scholars say even whatever
bad deeds you have when you repent can
be converted
into good deeds nothing's better that's
not great this is great thank you again
for be my pleasure indeed show exactly
before you thank you and you got to get
some good advice don't be a thug be
someone who is doing good being good and
calling others too good because you got
one shot you got one life to live so you
can go ahead and keep following your
lusts and desires and die in a bad state
or you can worship the One God not his
creation followed the last and final
messengers of sentiment kind of problem
i'm at peace be upon them and then you
can be in a constant state of
self-development striving to be the best
human being that you can be and then at
the end result is paradise and that's
what we're striving for we'll see you
next time God willing peace be unto you